monkey symbolism heights trash Apple
also this is an orgy of evidence that we
were in a poverty-stricken area of New
York City's history it's old time in New
York so obviously stickball even higher
Heights jeez I think I would rather have
three or four minutes of just opening
credits than have this book bit generic
old timey New York City bullet foxy
boxing first glimpse of real main
character buried in with stupid old
timey New York montage cliche wanton
destruction of delicious booze Peter
Jackson had to do this zoom cut because
Naomi Watts couldn't actually land the
hat-trick discount Brooks Hatlen
laughing the box office know which we'll
be crying over is the line the Witch and
the Wardrobe thumping your ass at the
box office
either this actor guy doesn't know this
obvious play is a play or an thinks the
guy doesn't know that this obvious play
is a play movie wastes the first 10
minutes on a character who's arguably
not even the main character of this
movie this hairpiece
are you good at crap in the crappers
phase a sizeable yes she is but she's
doing a picture with RKO haha regional
King Kong reference you want to read a
script Jack Driscoll's turning out draft
as we speak the screenwriter just
happens to be the same guy who ripped
the play that Anne was reading at the
beginning of the movie
you know also if this penniless
vaudeville performer wasn't already a
dedicated fan of the nobody author
writing Jack Black's screenplay then
we'd pretty much be forever kicking this
King Kong movie into gear three hours
late why is Driscoll even hanging out on
the boat then I only had to do was drop
off the script and he could have had
Carl's assistant Preston get that if he
had no intention of ever leaving on this
trip why did he show up on the boat if
the choice is to jump in the water and
swim a few feet or stay on a boat for
weeks that you didn't want to be on
fucking job right these cops took
forever to get here after we first heard
they would be showing up if only there
was some way the cops could catch that
boat oh wait New York had established a
harbor patrol unit well before the
setting of this movie and should easily
have been able to catch it what am I
thinking
modern kid-friendly CGI Peter Jackson
pays homage to earlier more daring Peter
Jackson movies what are you mr. Scott
launched imp NZ GZ just met this guy how
do you go from zero to dick measuring
asshole in two seconds easy-to-read
label is easy to read I'm calling
bullshit on Jack having a typewriter he
didn't bring one this is a boat used for
illegal activity and probably it doesn't
employ anyone who can type and I doubt
Carl would have been thoughtful enough
to carry one on board it's just a lie
sit down yeah so I found them four years
ago did Driscoll ask for a history on
Jimmy rehearsing how you're gonna talk
to someone you really love in a mirror
cliche Andy Serkis is playing a human
being in this scene you don't look at
all like your photograph wait she's seen
a picture of Jack and she made the
enormous leap that this was him in a
three and a half hour movie we
definitely don't need this book yes be
sure to spell it out so Jimmy can hear
it we interrupt this King Kong movie to
bring you Titanic I'll make it worth
your while
why does anyone trust Carl Denham he
hasn't paid any money to anyone this
whole movie and now a captain who fears
for his safety going to Skull Island is
just gonna do it because of the promise
of money Southwest oz9 why would this
boat turn Southwest then they launch
from New York that means an easterly
direction for most of the trip unless
they decided to travel south from New
York and then west through the Americas
but then you would never really have to
turn Southwest after that and that trip
would be super long that in the next
morning is stuck in North through his
huh this castaway who survived a
shipwreck a giant ape and drifting at
sea for days was a huge bundle of
exposition before he decided to kill
himself as want out for your arrest
you're just now getting this message
you've been traveling for however long
it takes for a boat to go nine thousand
miles
no one ever noticed this obvious skull
on the map before the ship blink owes
its way through the rocks without sink
boat that spends weeks searching for
mysterious secret island gives up and
heads for Rangoon and of course that's
how they find the secret island it's
screen writing 101 really how did Carl
convince everyone to get on this rowboat
after the ship it wrecked and not only
that get qualified personnel to help
lower the boat and put it out to sea
without anyone seen before it was too
late
every single person on this boat
including Jack and Anne said yeah let's
shoot a movie our only hope to get home
is stuck in some rocks okay movie rips
off the rock formations look like the
thing the movie is about thing from cars
the natives are dicks to Poindexter's
also the natives randomly killed this
one guy but for the rest of the sequence
grab each person one by one and take
them to some head-chopping place so that
the captain can save the day later
it takes a full hour before we even hear
King Kong in the King Kong movie haze is
definitely on the ship when Kong roars
but then somehow he and the rest of the
crew show up with guns literally two
minutes later and that's with all the
in-between footage being slowed down
there's no way thing up on the ship to
here in two minutes considering how long
it took Carl and the actors to get here
in the first place
seriously you believe that how can
everyone around Carl be this fucking
stupid old wall ting Jack sees the skull
necklace and says yep a native probably
pull both it onto the ship then he asks
this random guy doing important work
where Han is instead of just going to a
room the most natural place for her to
be right now if this native guy have a
GPS of where Han was how do you get on
the ship and run past everyone
undetected kidnap Ann and go back
through the ship with an unwilling
participant not once run past Jack who
found the guys necklace and is looking
for tied the rope back around himself an
an and swim back while keeping his
hostage alive while being pulled by
these helpful people back onto the
island it takes 1 hour and 10 minutes
for King Kong to show up in a movie
called King Kong also in the original
King Kong had already kicked a bunch of
dinosaur ass by the time this move even
shows him and we've got two more hours
to go for some reason unnecessary orders
getting thrown by a trike tusks merely
inconveniences Jack Leung he managed to
bring a frying pan
during the mad rush off the ship to save
an so many 15 dinosaurs King Kong is a
secondary character in his own movie
also dr. grant my dear dr. Sadler
welcome to Jurassic Park I guessed at
half after everyone pronouncing the name
Denham the entire movie and this actor
having worked with denim on previous
pictures it's suddenly dead hands
polite debris character falls down while
running away from danger cliche if the
brontosauruses are not about to stomp on
Carl here then don't show them about to
stomp on Carl then have the entire
exchange between he and Jack and then
pretend like the bronto's are still the
same distance away that they were before
is this asshole doing sleeping under all
these heavy rocks in case someone takes
cover here the ship and film crew all
survived the annual running of the
dinosaurs also running up the dinosaurs
all Jack had to do was slightly nudge
this ferocious beast to send it flying
there goes that scurvy dog Jimmy Wilhelm
dying another height related death this
is like Blues Brothers with bronto's
and everyone survives the dinosaur
pile-up I mean this is the same movie
where a dude died from a single spear to
the chest so it's not like this is a
cartoon universe where injury and death
are impossible and yet it is and donate
the proceeds to his wife and kids
only now does Preston realize what an
asshole Carl is Andy Serkis isn't
getting nominated for an Oscar in this
scene King Kong is a dick to his dinner
giant piranha is only satisfied if it
eats its very whole so the giant piranha
Thane can't swim between these huge gaps
here why does this movie spend so much
time on these two Jack and Anne aren't
even as developed as these two yeah save
Jimmy above everyone else
he's the blondest don't give me a
fucking break already these assholes all
fall off this log only after the drop is
reduced to a few feet CGI giant bugs and
is saved by a spare t-rex that was
walking around we interrupt this King
Kong movie to bring you the kind of King
Kong movie you actually wanted to see
but only for a few minutes geography
Savior also sudden steep mud slide
through rocky island terrain doesn't
cause an any injury whatsoever surprise
t-rex would rather be scary than eat and
right now you know for All Hands been
through in this movie she's still
looking dynamite
what's better than to t-rexes three
t-rexes you know the scene is perfectly
fine nothing in general simple about it
it's just it
I am giant monster out in this movie
we've just now hit the two-hour mark can
there really be another hour in 20
minutes to go Ginny shoots blindly and
hits the insects but doesn't hit jack
more CGI giant bugs Jesus if it wasn't
for the quality actors and the directors
pedigree this would basically be one of
those Brendan Fraser Journey to the
Center of the Earth movies right Peter
Jackson's giant arachnid fetish wimpy
actor guy suddenly has the balls to
swing on a vine with a machine gun to
murder giant scorpions man and must have
gotten to take a shower and go to the
hairstylist twice since we last saw for
someone who slid down a muddy hill and
fell into water her appearance is
incredibly resilient Stockholm Syndrome
she's not dead Jack's gonna bring her
back Carl is both insane and right
miraculous escape made possible by
convenient stupid bats is it impossible
to go back where you came from sure
there were bats there but all the bats
are fighting King Kong right now
all right you just got out of a river
how are they this many sailors still
left over after all the ones who got
eaten stomp drown or thrown off cliffs
longest chloroforming scene ever the
whole world will pay to see this they'll
have to come to the island then because
there's no way this giant ape is lifted
onto the boat or that there's any room
for him but this is a detail the movie
will skirt obviously just like the lost
world Jurassic Park this movie still has
a whole other movie to show you after
they get back to the mainland wait Jack
was writing this comedy play for Anne
while they were on the boat and then the
whole King Kong Island thing happened
and now they're back and either Denham
has been sitting on this King Kong
reveal for a long time or else the
lonely playwright managed to get an
entire production funded cast rehearsed
and opened in like days playwright as a
dick to his own play no doubt about it
this theater is huge one question though
is there a giant entrance for King Kong
to fit through to get into this theater
I'll offer advice to anyone planning on
making a three-and-a-half-hour giant ape
movie
don't put scenes like this in at the to
our own 40-minute mark it will put
everyone right to sleep Wow Kong sure
knows how to kill characters that aren't
the main characters hey it's times like
this I wonder what's going on with Jimmy
the thieving deckhand who was reading
heart of darkness
too bad Hayes died Stockholm Syndrome
also the entire city evacuated in order
for King Kong and Ann to have their
reunion there's not even one accidental
car driving through this right now Oh
romantic ice skating in Central Park we
interrupt this King Kong movie to bring
you serendipity I guess geez did the
soldiers need propaganda to get in the
mood to fight a giant ape also humans
man humans are bad well I'm glad the
movie took the time to set up that joke
discount authorities and it's nearly
invisible at this distance especially
with the sky in the background but the
pilot decides they sees a woman in white
anyway
don't we talked it over and decided a
girl
we're shooting me sunrise I mean what
the time was Carl's big King Kong
reveals stage show then did it have a
start time of like 4 a.m. and then a
small gust of wind picked up and blew
them to their deaths
it wasn't the airplanes it was Beauty
killed the Beast
or the runtime of this movie did you
ever consider Kong died of old age even
before we knew we were related we'd
always known there was part of them in
US and part of us in them
[Music]
if the Bible is taught us nothing else
and it hasn't
it's that girls should stick to girls
sports such as hot oil wrestling foxy
boxing and such and say hey I heard what
going to a violin
yeah the capture each other date I wish
we were going to candy apple Allen candy
apple Island what do they got their Apes
but they're not so big phrasing me
[Music]
I know he's here go to the next bedroom
the bed is very important
they're moving in herds
they do move in herds
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not your fault
what happened at herb is no one's fault
with me alright don't play me Sean not
you it's not your fault
[Music]